-Thank you for being here fo
one of our live shows.
-A live show.
It's an amazing concept.
-Have you ever considered
doing your show live?
-[ Laughs ]
I was joking backstage.
I was like,
"This is a big deal, live.
-Yeah.
-We do this every night.
-Yeah, you do it
every single night.
Every single night.
You turn it around really fast
Tonight was
a little strange for you,
because you were doing your show
during the first hour
of the debate.
-It's so weird that we've ha
this two nights in a row.
I mean, the first time, we had
the debates on MSNBC, right?
So, these ones, we did not have.
They were only on CNN.
They're only on the networ
that gets them.
And you're in that
segment meeting.
It's like, "Should we not
mention the debate
because maybe on the off chanc
we remind someone
it's happening
and they turn over there?"
-Yeah.
-That's kind of dumb. They know.
-Because I feel like the peopl
who watch your show
are obviously invested
in politics,
so it seems like
a very small slice of people
that would be, like,
invested in politics
but also not
care about the debates.
-Well, thank you.
-Yeah.
-I like to think of the people
invested in politics
invested in me.
-Yeah, that's true.
-Which is a small number,
as the ratings showed.
-But, obviously,
you managed to go back.
You watched the debate.
A lot about healthcare tonight
-Yes.
-Substantive, I think.
Sometimes, I would imagine
for most people,
a little hard to follow.
Do you feel like the candidate
do a good job
laying out what their
differences are
in regards to healthcare?
-I thought the first night
was actually sharper on this
because the access
was very clear.
It was two people were
advocating Medicare for all.
Single payer.
Everyone enrolls in one plan
There will be no
private plans anymore.
We'll transition that.
And then other people
attacking that.
And I actually
think Medicare for all --
Whatever you think about its
popularity or workability,
at least it is clear
what it is, right?
So, people can say, "Well, how
are you going to pay for it?
And I don't know if I
want to give up
my private health insurance.
But the sort of
lines of debate were clear
Tonight, with these more kin
of, like, half-measures
about the public option --
You'll have a $1,000 deductible,
and 8.6% of your income,
but not if you're --
You know, that gets
way, way, way harder to follow
-And then it becomes a bit --
feel as though the takeaway is
who's making the most effectiv
attack on someone else?
Tonight definitely seemed like
a night of attacking.
Joe Biden is obviously
the front-runner.
He's going to
take those attacks.
It seemed like, last night
they were making Delaney
the stand-in for Joe Biden
because he was sort of the
moderate who was there.
And despite polling at 1%,
he sort of had a starring role
-It was really funny,
because, obviously,
the thing that
we haven't seen yet is --
you want to see a stage that has
Harris, Buttigieg, Biden,
Warren, and Sanders together
Those are the people who are
polling in the top five.
And we haven't had that.
So, last night,
I think what CNN tried to do -
and it's not a
crazy approach to this --
is they were like,
"Let's just make someone
a Biden stand-in, because we
don't have Biden here."
And they were like,
"Who's the guy at the end?
Delaney. Let's do him."
-Yeah.
He was like Brad Pitt
to Leonardo in
"Once Upon a Time in Hollywood."
-Yeah. I haven't seen it yet
-It's a stuntman joke, yeah.
Not a lot of people have.
And then I want to ask about
the issue of electability.
Obviously, this is a questio
that's coming out right now.
And one thing
that people ask is,
"Is this good for people
to be attacking everyone?"
Does that weaken a candidate
when they go
to the general election?
You could argue, certainly
in the last election,
Hillary Clinton
didn't have to go through
this sort of trial by a
bunch of candidates,
maybe a little bit with Bernie
but it certainly wasn't this
Do you feel like it's
good or bad
for whoever emerges from this to
have been sort of attacked by,
at one point, you know,
22 different other candidates?
-You know, I don't really know
that I know the answer to that
I mean, in some ways,
it's unavoidable,
so who's to say
whether it's good or bad?
It's going to happen.
I mean, you know,
politics is about conflict
And I think that what
I would say about
the first four debates in th
Democratic Party is --
they have been substantive
Like, people do disagree about
whether we should have
a single-payer system or not
There are arguments
on both sides
that are not, like,
you know, trivial.
There are real arguments
on both sides,
and those need to be hashed out.
People disagree about whether we
should decriminalize
unauthorized entry to
the United States,
which is currently
a criminal misdemeanor
but could be handled as
a civil matter.
There are people on
different sides of that.
It's good to fight about
that stuff.
Like, it's good
to fight about that stuff
and it is inevitable
to fight about that stuff.